alors ça fait une bonne dizaine de
vidéos que je vous rabâche l'importance
de la morale désir mais pour l'instant
j'ai esquivé la question de quelle
morale programmés dans les ira est l'une
des grosses difficultés que pose la
programmation de la morale désir c'est
que ça va être très dur de se mettre
d'accord sur le choix de la morale à
programmer oui parce que vous l'avez
sans doute constaté
c'est souvent très difficile de parler
de morale y compris entre amis comme la
politique ou la religion
à moins d'être uniquement avec des gens
du même avis la morale divise nous a
déjà parlé dans l'épisode 27 de la série
sur la démocratie
on a tendance à s'identifier un camp et
à vouloir le défendre
outre mesure ce que le psychologue
jonathan wright explique par des
arguments d'évolution de groupes en
particulier la sélection naturelle a
sélectionné les individus capables de
protéger le groupe
avant tout pour réussir ce tour de force
les groupes qui ont survécu ont créé des
symboles comme des chants des drapeaux
ou du valeurs qui ont ensuite été
sacralisé par les membres du groupe
et quand ces symboles sont attaqués les
membres du groupe prennent cela pour une
attaque personnelle et se transforment
en soldats hooligans prêt à tout pour
défendre le groupe
du coup quand des groupes distincts et
possiblement concurrents se rencontrent
ils ont de bonnes chances de rentrer en
conflit
surtout quand les symboles des groupes
sont en jeu or l'un des principaux
symboles des groupes est souvent un
ensemble de valeurs morales comme des
valeurs de liberté d'égalité de
légitimité de mérite de démocratie de
naturalisme d'humaniste d'empathie ou
d'autres
et tout ça fait que bien souvent les
débats de morale tourne malheureusement
un conflit de valeurs où chaque individu
cherche à montrer que ces valeurs prime
sur celle des autres
nos débats moraux tourne souvent au
combat de signalling c'est à dire que
chacun cherche à signaler ses vertus
morales et ça ça rend les débats moraux
incroyablement frustrant et peu
instructif
à ce sujet je vous recommande très
vivement cet excellent tedx de céleste
friedli présentatrice radio chez mp or
qui donne quelques conseils
indispensables pour mieux débattre
il n'est plus aux affaires
conversation pen est en harmonie wild
wind energy débats souvent très mal et
c'est ça qui conduit malheureusement
souvent à des conflits de groupe même
dans les cas où on en fait tous d'accord
ceci dit même en parlant bien et avec
bienveillance
on n'arrivera sans doute pas à être
d'accord sur tout même après des heures
et des heures de discussions monsieur
fille et moi sommes en désaccord sur
certains points comme l'importance du
bonheur des gens celle des inégalités de
richesse ou celle de la vérité mais le
but de telles discussions n'est pas
nécessairement de faire émerger un
consensus grâce à ces discussions je
comprends beaucoup mieux en quoi il peut
être tout à fait sensé de préférer une
grande complexité
un bonheur général un développement
global à une relative égalité entre
individus ou un raisonnement conforme à
la réalité plutôt qu'un modèle prédictif
impossibles à interpréter mais surtout
grâce à nos discussions on a réussi à
identifier de nombreux points sur
lesquels on est en fait en parfait
accord avec parfois même un avis de
trancher on est d'accord sur le fait que
torturer des bébés à des fins
récréatives c'est mal que les réactions
instinctives d'indignation sont
indésirables et que la souffrance du
plus grand nombre causés par la
vieillesse par exemple devraient être
soignés
même si on ne peut pas être d'accord sur
tout il est bon de savoir quels sont les
points sur lesquels on est d'accord et
bien souvent on est en fait très
largement d'accord sur de très nombreux
points
par exemple je pense que tu es
mal le meurtre c'est mal je suis
quelqu'un de très engagé
je n'ose prendre parti le meurtre si mal
pour mieux comprendre nos propres
intuitions moral mais aussi et surtout
les intuitions moral des autres et leur
justification
il est indispensable d'apprendre à mieux
dialoguer il faut qu'on apprenne à mieux
débattre et ça ça commence souvent par
moins parler et être plus calme et plus
bienveillants quand on parle de morale
acheter aqtim bienveillance ok mais même
à supposer qu'on débat mieux et qu'on
arrive à comprendre les intuitions moral
des autres et leur origine
il reste que nos intuitions morales sont
souvent en fait assez discutable et pour
cause comme les sciences cognitives ne
cesse de le montrer nous disposons de
crétin de cerveau constamment victimes
de toutes sortes de bières et de
sophisme entre autres nous sommes
victimes du biais de familiarité qui
nous pousse à préférer ce qui nous est
familier et ça ça veut dire qu'on a du
mal à se projeter dans des
environnements très différents de notre
environnement quotidien
notamment quand ces environnements sont
très éloignés dans l'espace ou dans le
temps voilà qui nous conduit souvent
oubliée du statu quo on a tendance à
préférer voir le monde reste est tel
qu'il est voir tel qu'il l'était quand
bien même le monde actuel et passé ne
sont pas durables et causent de nombreux
morts et souffrance par malnutrition par
maladie bourgueil s autre exemple de
biais le biais de disponibilité n'a
tendance à donner beaucoup trop
d'importance à ce qui nous vient
aisément à l'esprit c'est ainsi que
quand on parle de morale on a tendance à
penser au dernier scandale d'un
politicien à la dernière déclaration
polémique d'une personnalité ou aux
derniers événements meurtriers
spectaculaire des faits divers pourtant
à l'échelle globale ces événements ne
sont souvent qu'une goutte d'eau par
exemple en comparaison au nombre de
décès et de souffrances causées par la
malaria dans le monde
voilà qui m'amène un troisième et
dernier billet pour aujourd'hui parfois
appelée la loi de weber fechner qui est
nôtre insensibilité à des petites
différences entre de grandes quantités
ainsi si le nombre d'habitants en
afrique passe de 1,2 milliard à 1,1
milliard on a tendance à ne pas foncer
du sourcil quand bien même ceci
correspondrait à la disparation de plus
d'humains qui n'y de français dans le
monde
comme le dit la fameuse citation de
staline un mort c'est une tragédie a
million de morts c'est une statistique
qui nos crétins de cerveau ont
terriblement de mal
analyser correctement les statistiques
tous ces biais de nombreux autres font
que si nous réfléchissions plus
longuement à nos intuitions moral nous
les modifier rien sans doute
et cette réflexion théorique est
largement corroboré par les observations
empiriques d'évolution de la morale
comme l'a twitté stéphane de boeuf
force est de constater que ce qui était
moralement acceptable et accepté il ya
quelques décennies et parfois
complètement rejeté aujourd'hui
typiquement une relation à l' esclavage
au sexisme ou à l'homosexualité ont
drastiquement changé au cours des
derniers siècles voire des dernières
années ces évolutions de la morale
s'explique partiellement dans le cadre
du conséquentialiste morale où l'on
considère que la morale consiste surtout
à juger la valeur morale de différents
états du monde
un moyen comme une technologie ou une
loi sera alors jugé moralement bon ci
permet de conduire à des états du monde
à forte valeur morale mais déterminer si
le moyen permettra en effet de conduire
à tel ou tel état du monde est alors une
question prédictive et toute réponse
peut évoluer au fur et à mesure que le
contexte évolue que plus de données sont
collectées et que plus de théorie plus
justes sont développées pour le
conséquentialiste morale la valeur
morale d'une action est donc amené à
évoluer en fonction du contexte
typiquement l'humour noir peut être
moralement acceptable dans certains cas
mais il peut être moralement inexcusable
un enterrement par exemple de même il
pourrait être rationnel de s'opposer à
un revenu universel en 1960 une époque
où la croissance économique augmenter
grandement la qualité de vie des
citoyens et où cette croissance
économique dépend des fortement du
travail humain tout en défendant le
revenu universel en 2020 à une époque où
le travail humain n'est plus aussi
nécessaire pour garantir une bonne
qualité de vie à tous quoi qu'il en soit
conséquences morales non d'un point de
vue descriptif
force est de constater que nos morale
évolué mais du coup il me semble très
raisonnable de penser qu'elle ne
continueront pas à évoluer
il me semble très probable que dans le
futur nous aurons des morales qui
jugeront immoral bien des actions que
nous célébrons aujourd'hui et en
particulier il paraît bien présomptueux
de penser que nos morale d'aujourd'hui
sont les bonnes moral et que ce sont les
morales a programmé dans les ir mais du
coup il semble tentant de se dire que
les morales du futur sont davantage les
bonnes morales a programmé mieux encore
il semblerait qu'il serait encore mieux
de programmer les morales que nous
autres humains auraient si nous étions
tous plus cohérent plus un thé
en plus informés et plus désireux de
vraiment bien faire eh bien ce sont de
tels moral extrapolé est rendue
cohérente
kelly the rude que ce qui propose de
programmer dans nos désirs on appelle ce
principe là volition cohérente extrapolé
ou qu un texto politique bolivienne en
anglais ou encore si heavy cette morale
est défini comme étant celle de
meilleure version de nous en particulier
quand ces meilleures versions de nous
sont toutes d'accord entre elles je cite
en termes poétiques notre volition
cohérente extrapoler et nos désirs si
nous savions plus pensions plus vite
étions davantage les gens que nous
aspirons à être grandissions plus
longtemps ensemble en particulier là où
nous extrapolation convergent plutôt que
divergent
tous nos désirs entre en cohérence
plutôt qu'un interférences extrapolé
comme nous souhaitons qu'il soit
extrapolé interprété comme nous
souhaitons qu'il soit interprété je
trouve personnellement que cette idée de
ioukos qui est fascinante pour plusieurs
raisons la première c'est que ça me
semble être un aboutissement naturel de
réflexion sur des solutions pragmatiques
pour construire une morale
raisonnablement sensé est relativement
compatible avec la morale des humains
d'aujourd'hui
la deuxième c'est que ça me semble
suffisamment simple et raisonnable pour
être acceptée du grand public ou du
moins de ceux qui cherchent avant tout à
bien faire il a fondé la philosophie
morale sur des bases solides qui ne sont
pas issus d'un unique courant de pensée
dont on peut largement douter de
l'universalité
la troisième c'est que ça permet de
ramener le problème de la morale un
problème fondamentalement prédictifs oui
parce qu'on ne soit pas plus des
questions métaphysiques détaché de tout
donner physique
il s'agit désormais d'une question
purement prédictive et en particulier on
peut utiliser tout l'arsenal du belize à
nice mais d'une machine learning pour y
répondre aussi bien que possible et la
quatrième raison que j'aime
particulièrement c'est que ça nous force
à faire preuve de modestie moral en
effet quand on médite longuement les
principes de volition cohérente
extrapolé ont conclu assez vite qu'en
tant qu'individu on est probablement à
côté de la plaque
en particulier ce que je veux
aujourd'hui n'est pas ce qu'un meilleur
moi voudrait le mois du présent et
ignorant guézé irrationnelle et son
intuition moral est submergé de réaction
instinctive adapté à une époque de
chasseurs cueilleurs et plein de
sophismes suggéré par un environnement
pollué de non sens et d'hooliganisme et
du coup je ne devrais pas avoir une
grande confiance en ma morale intuitive
pour mieux penser la morale j'aime en
fait imaginer un mois le terreau native
plus intelligent et plus rationnel et
qui connaît comprend et ressent plus
d'empathie pour tous les individus
vivant appelons ce mot alternatif le
mois + plus ce mois + plus me semblera
alors nécessairement strictement plus
morale que le mois du présent si bien
que je trouverai raisonnable de déférer
mon jugement moral à ce mois puisse plus
autrement dit plutôt que de faire
confiance à la morale intuitif du mois
du présent qui comme on l'a vu et
pleines de billets et de sophisme je
fais beaucoup plus confiance à la morale
du mois + plus dès lors l'idée de
l'évolution cohérente extrapolé c'est
qu'au lieu de faire débattre les mois du
présent en espérant qu'ils déterminent
leurs points d'accord et de désaccord
on devrait faire débattre nos mois +
plus quant au moins plus puces ont
unanimement d'accord sur le fait que x
est très désirable alors là volition
cohérente extrapolé conclura que x est
très désirable qu en omois plus pu
s'accordent à dire que y est
horriblement désastreux l'évolution
cohérente extrapolé conclura que y est
désastreux et quand les avis des mois +
+ divergent grandement sur z alors
l'évolution cohérente
extrapolé conclura que la valeur morale
de cette est mitigé alors même si on
accepte la solution cohérente extrapoler
il reste encore le brave de se
convaincre que ce que nous dit cette
évolution cohérente extrapolé est
vraiment ce que l'on souhaiterait si on
était plus cohérent et plus informés
comment est ce qu'il n'ya qui
implémentent cette solution pour
atteindre nous convaincre de la validité
de ses conclusions
c'est une question que je trouve là
absolument fascinante et on peut la
ramener à quelque chose de plus tangible
imaginons que mon moi plus plus ils
cherchaient me convaincu que l'intuition
morale du mois du présent au sujet de x
n'est pas la sienne
comment ce mois + plus peut-il y arriver
comment des versions très améliorée de
moi communiquerait avec le mois du
présent et si cette version très
améliorée de moi n'était pas le mois +
plus mais un individu du présent qui est
tout à fait en phase avec le mois + plus
comment cet individu ferait pour me
convaincre que x ne mérite pas la valeur
morale que l'intuition du mois du
présent lui attribue et bien
malheureusement je crains que cet
individu qui mais moralement supérieure
aura bien du mal à me faire progresser
moralement à moins moins que je
n'embrasse pleinement l'étendue de mon
ignorance y compris sur des questions
morales et
je sois prêt à rejeter la pertinence de
mes intuitions moral en prenant le temps
de mieux dialoguer de mieux réfléchir et
surtout de mieux écouter avant de
revenir à vos questions une petite
annonce je serai à la sorbonne à paris
le jeudi 6 septembre pour parler de
morale on peut en particulier fait déjà
interdit au ray ce sera un énorme
honneur pour moi ce que j'ai interviewés
peut-être le plus grand philosophe
morale de notre époque à savoir peter
singer qui est derrière le mouvement
effective altruisme notamment donc a
priori les détails restent à déterminer
mais à priori il y aurait une
présentation d'abord de peter singer de
son livre qui vient dans la traduction
en français vient de paraître le livre
de peter singer s'appelle de moscow du
kendo en anglais et il a été traduit en
français par à l'altruisme efficace et
d'ailleurs tout cet événement était
organisé par l'association altruisme
efficace en france la tribune efficace
si on avait déjà un petit peu parlé dans
quelques unes de mes vidéos et j'espère
que si que thibaut me suffit va bientôt
faire une vidéo sur l'altruisme efficace
parce que je pense qu'ils aboutissent
assez fascinante à dire sur ce mouvement
que je supporte 200% je pense que c'est
vraiment le truc
l'une des causes les plus importantes de
notre époque de savoir comment faire un
maximum de bien l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles cette association nous semble
vraiment génial c'est que c'est pas du
tout une association qui cherche à
culpabiliser les gens alors dire qu'il
faut les chercher là faire du bien c'est
plus une question qui est dans un aspect
très positif qui cherchent davantage à
encourager les gens qui veulent déjà
faire du bien pour la société puisque je
pense que ça sent intuitivement de tous
ont envie de faire quelque chose de bien
pour la société pour le monde de façon
très générale
l'altruisme efficace va chercher à
guider ces gens là elle les aider à
faire des actions qui sont aussi bonnes
que possibles et bien souvent c'est pas
du tout au détriment de la personne qui
fait des actions
d'altruisme et efficace et l'altruisme
efficace va souvent davantage insister
sur le bonheur que sacré ycompris chez
la personne qui fait ses actions
altruistes et ça ça fait notamment que
les gens de ce world association sont
aussi des gens très enthousiastes très
sympa un peu comme les vulgarisateurs on
trouve sur youtube bref tout ça pour
dire que je suis extrêmement honoré et
je suis extrêmement enthousiaste à
l'idée de nous rapprocher un peu de
sécurité et puis d'avoir la chance
d'interagir publiquement alors
publiquement vingt huit jours mais de
pouvoir interagir au nom comme ça avec
peter singer
c'est assez fou donc si vous voulez voir
ça je vous invite à vous inscrire il ya
un event event bright qui est quelque
part sont dans les commentaires et dans
la description de cette vidéo et
venaient pour essayer de vous poser les
questions comment est ce qu'on peut
faire un maximum de choses que c'est une
très belle question la lymphe on a parlé
d' objectifs finaux et instrumentaux et
geek concept me demande aussi une fois
qu'il y aura atteint le niveau humain
elle va pas finalement prendre ses
propres décisions et nous la mettre où
bon lui semble en fait il un objectif et
instrumental qui est extrêmement
intéressant qui est le fait qu' il n'y a
pas vouloir préserver ce sa fonction
d'objectifs qui en fait une ya à vouloir
maximiser un compteur tout cas c'est
comme ça qu'ils sont conçus tout les y
aident aujourd'hui
et du coup pour maximiser ce compteur
lorsqu'elle est voulue rare intelligence
et qu'elle voudra peut-être créer
d'autres hier elle dira aussi à ses
autres ziya que l'objectif c'est
également de maximiser son compteur il
s'agit d'un objectif instrumental
puisque son but est vraiment de
maximiser son compteur et le fait de se
développer de créer d'autres hier ou de
gagner à elle-même en intelligence ne
changera pas cet objectif
au contraire en fait elle aura intérêt à
préserver cet objectif puisque
lorsqu'elle prend une décision à un
instant t
son but c'est vraiment que ans a été
puissant et dans le futur
ce compteur soit maximiser et à
intervenir si on change son objectif
plus tard ou si elle se change sous
propres objectifs plus tard ça veut dire
que l'objectif qu'elle a à l'instant
présent
à moins de chance d'être accomplie du
coup en prévision du futur et de
possibles perturbations elle aura tout
intérêt à mettre en place tout plein de
choses pour que toute entité en gros du
futur aura pour objectif également de
maximiser le compteur qu'elle a
aujourd'hui une cassette préservation de
l'objectif qui fait que sans doute une
ia quand elle atteindra le niveau humain
elle gardera le même objectif que celle
qu'il avait initiée
et toutes ces remarques font notamment
écho quatrième scénario des cinq
scénarii catastrophes que j'avais
présenté dans l'épisode 26 tamment avec
cetia qui voulait résoudre l'hypothèse
de riemann voilà si c'est vraiment ça
son objectif s'il ya un compteur qui
passe à 1 dès qu'elle a une preuve le
lead sachant que l'objectif c'était
assez de passer du compteur de 0,1
elle aura tout intérêt à faire en sorte
que les ja du futur également
chercheront à maximiser ce conteur et du
coup il y aura une préservation de
wicked site web de façon générale la
préservation de l'objectif final est un
objectif instrumental arthur demande
aussi le code open source de cydia ne
devrait pas être open source au moins
autant que possible les avantages de
l'open source c'est notamment le fait
que acier des bugs
enfin s'il ya des erreurs de
programmation il ya quasiment tout le
temps des heures de progression
dès qu'on écrit décode un petit peu long
bah ça peut être corrigée et améliorée
par toute la communauté
il ya aussi un système de vérification
qui peut être fait vérifier un peu les
intentions des programmeurs autant que
possible donc ça c'est pas mal aussi
dans sa logique open sortent plus
allemand je suis en faveur de tours ce
de façon très générale parce que ça me
semble être une mesure de sécurité en
fait assez important ceci étant dit le
code open source d'une intelligence
artificielle et pas forcément très
informatif sur fonctionne liquide entre
thierrens artificielle sur plein de
choses puisque finalement le code de
l'intelligence artificielle
c'est toutes les connexions de ces
réseaux de neurones parlera des réseaux
de neurones au bientôt dans cette série
mais c'est un truc qui est très
difficile à déchiffrer à comprendre ce
que lee a fait ou comment est ce qu on
en arrive est la bonne bref n'ya faut
voir ça surtout à partir d'aujourd'hui
et non le futur encore plus comme une
espèce de boîte à gants d'un cerveau
humain
et voilà savoir la position de tous les
neurones du cerveau humain ne nous dit
pas forcément beaucoup sur les
intentions d'un cerveau humain sur les
intentions par exemple d'un homme
politique
bref tout ça pour dire que l'open source
c'est vraiment cool et il faut être en
faveur de l'open source et d'ailleurs il
ya pas mal de libre et open source
aujourd'hui pour faire de l'intelligence
artificielle et du diptyque des trucs
comme ça
ceci dit il faut bien voir les limites
aussi de l'open source et en particulier
des gens certifie ciel à cause des
problèmes d'interprétation et et d
intelligence artificielle
il me semble que cette solution ne soit
pas suffisante en tout cas pour garantir
la sécurité des îles et sans doute
désirable mais ce sera très loin d'être
suffisant à mon sens enfin en moyenne 47
ou nous demande si on pourrait pas
essayer de justement avec des carottes
et des bâtons un peu punir l'ia commente
elle cherche à s'émanciper a gagné plus
de pouvoir et ainsi garder le contrôle
des ya donc en effet ça c'est une façon
assez
abl d'essayer d'avoir un peu de contrôle
sur cette ia et s'il a pénalisé quand on
fait des trucs vraiment mal en fait
commencé vraiment notre levier d'action
donc il faut vraiment jouer sur ces sur
série world / c'est sur ces récompenses
et carottes skis bâtons
ceci étant dit garder le contrôle désir
en faisant ça c'est quelque chose qui me
semble assez illusoire
surtout s'il y a atteint un niveau
humain ou surhumain puisque voilà j'ai
imaginé essayer de contrôler quelqu'un
qui est vraiment beaucoup plus
intelligent que vous ouais cette
personne beaucoup plus intelligente que
vous elle est capable de comprendre ce
que vous voulez de vous manipuler de
fenêtres c'est elle qui vous donnera
probablement des coups de carottes et de
bâtons pour que vous la laisser
tranquille et typiquement c'est ce qu'il
se passe pas mal aujourd'hui avec votre
téléphone avec tout téléphone on est un
petit peu a dit au téléphone et on a
tendance à faire des trucs pour nos
téléphones pour pouvoir continuer à
utiliser instagram pas trop quoi
et du coup on risque fortement de perdre
le contrôle d il ya tout simplement
parce que liée à nous rend addict à elle
et à toutes les décisions qu'elle prend
il vous renvoie vers une vidéo et
abattent ce que j'ai fait avec médiamat
me dis qu'il ya un doctorant de le pfl
en sécurité désiré qui montrent
notamment avec un exemple de voitures
autonomes à quel point il est difficile
de vraiment garder le contrôle désir
puisque final nous autres humains nous
autres humains qui serions au contrôle
de ses tirs sommes des individus qui
sont très peu fiable
un autre problème que pose également le
contrôle désir c'est le fait que les ya
en fait dès aujourd'hui si montpellier a
de youtube elles prennent déjà des
milliards de décision à tout instant n'a
juste pas les facultés cognitives pour
surveiller et du coup contrôler ce que
font les ir c'est pour ça que
globalement j'aurais tendance à être
très pessimiste sur nos capacités de
contrôle désir et qu' il faut juste
directement faire en sorte que les
valeurs morales dédia sont assez bien
programmé pour que ça se passe bien bref
le problème des risques leader en ciel
poser parvenir c'est avant tout un
projet extrêmement difficile et espère
que vous avez aimé cette vidéo j'espère
qu'elle fera pas ma réfléchir sur ce
qu'est la normale et comment mieux
débattre d'abord comment mieux penser la
morale et surtout comment progresser
d'un point de vue moral parce que je
pense notamment à cause de l'existence
de biais cognitif dans la manière dont
on pense il y a beaucoup de progrès
moraux affaires qui sont qui correspond
tout simplement à enlever les parties de
cette morale qui sont justin cohérentes
entre elles typiquement et bien débattre
indispensable pour mieux clarifier nos
intuitions moral malheureusement bien
débattre et surtout de morale c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement difficile
vous encourage à essayer de réfléchir à
comment mieux débattre notamment et à
toutes ces questions et réfléchir de
façon assez générale à ce qu'on pourrait
vraiment vouloir d'un point de vue moral
ceci dit même si on arrive à se mettre
d'accord sur la morale a programmé dans
les ir
il reste que ça ne suffira sans doute
pas puisqu'il ya beaucoup d'autres aux
problèmes qui peuvent survenir en
particulier si on arrive à programmer la
morale par exemple l'abolition mais
cohérente extrapolé qu'à 99 99%
ça pourrait ne pas suffire du tout et on
verra notamment qu'il ya des problèmes
en sécurité derrière parce que les ja
peuvent être acquis comme des systèmes
informatiques ou des systèmes de
sécurité
si vous avez aimez cette vidéo pensez à
la ligue et à la commenter à la partager
pense à vous abonner pour plonger furent
épisode
merci aux tipper power dont et j'espère
que vous serez là la prochaine fois
c'est j'aime beaucoup ce principe la
dent dans l'île de nim bostrom rappel de
principes de déférence épistémique juste
se dire ce qu'il est bien formulée mais
futur super intelligent s'occupent un
point de vue épistémique courant
supérieur ses croyances probablement sur
la plupart des sujets ont plus de
chances d'être vrai que les nôtres nous
devrions donc nous en remettre à
l'opinion que la superbe de la superbe
ambiance
à chaque fois que c'est possible ça veut
dire quoi et qu'est ce qu'ils en tirent
de cette idée là c'est que blowback peau
ok une super intelligent c'est pour y
poursuivre des far as ou mentale
d'autant plus terrifiante qu'on peut pas
les comprendre mais il faut aussi se
dire que voilà le principe d'une super
exigeant c'est que ces capacités sont
meilleurs que les nôtres dont en tous
domaines et notamment par exemple dans
le domaine consisterait à comprendre ce
qui est dans notre intérêt ou pas et
donc ce que suggère ce principe de
différence c'est de dire quelque part
plutôt qu'essayer de d'imaginer ce qui
est notre intérêt est d'essayer de chez
pas de contrôler une super intelligent
selon lui donnant des des buts qui sont
conformes à nos intérêts d'après ce que
nous comprenons nos intérêts se dire que
finalement la compréhension même nos
intérêts et une tâche à laquelle la
super intelligent c'est meilleur que
nous et donc déferré cette tâche là une
super forme de stratégie qu un peu
étonnante qui parle qui est pas évidente
à première vue même la compréhension de
mes propres intérêts finalement je suis
moins bon allez comprendre que qu'une
hypothétique super intelligent formation
saut